we're told of the quadratic expressions
M squared minus 4m minus 45 and 6 and
squared minus 150 share a common
binomial factor what binomial factor do
they share and like always pause the
video and see if you can work through
this alright now let's work through this
together and the way I'm going to do is
I'm just gonna try to factor both of
them into the product of binomials and
maybe some other things and see if we
have any common binomial factors
so first let's focus on M squared minus
4m minus 45 so let me write it over here
M squared minus 4m minus 45 so when
you're factoring a quadratic expression
like this where the coefficient on the
in this case M squared term on the
second degree term is one we could
factor it as being equal to M plus a
times M plus B where a plus B is going
to be equal to this coefficient right
over here and a times B is going to be
equal to this coefficient right over
here so let's be clear so a there's a
another color so a plus B needs to be
equal to negative 4 a plus B it needs to
be equal to negative 4 and then a times
B needs to be equal to negative 45 a
times B is equal to negative 45 now I
like to focus on the a times B and think
about well what could a and B be to get
to negative 45 well if I'm taking the
product of two things and if the product
is negative that means that they're
going to have different signs and if
when we add them we get a negative
number that means that the that the the
negative 1 has a larger has a larger
magnitude so let's think about this a
little bit so a times B is equal to
negative 45 so this could be let's try
some some values out so one in 45 those
are too far apart let's see 3 and 15
those still seem pretty far apart let's
see it looks like 5 and 9 seem interests
so if we say if we say five times if we
were to say five times negative nine
that indeed is equal to negative forty
five and five plus negative nine is
indeed equal to negative four so a could
be equal to five and B could be equal to
negative nine and so if we were to
factor this this is going to be M plus
five times M I could say M plus negative
nine but I'll just write M minus nine so
just like that I've been able to factor
I've been able to factor this first
quadratic expression right over there as
a product of two binomials so now let's
try to factor the other quadratic
expression let's try to factor 6m
squared minus 150 and let's see the
first thing I might want to do is both
six both 6m squared and one fifty
they're both divisible by six so let me
write it this way I could write it as
six actually I'll just write 6m squared
minus six times let's see six goes into
150 twenty-five times so all I did is I
rewrote this and I just really I just
wrote 150 is six times twenty-five and
now you can clearly see that we can
factor out a 6 you can view this as
undistributing the six so this is the
same thing as 6 times M squared minus 25
which we recognize this is a difference
of squares so it's all going to be 6
times M plus 5 times M minus 5 and so
we've factored this out as a product of
binomials and some and and a constant
factor here 6 and so what is their
shared common where does their common
binomial factor that they share well you
see when we factor it out they both have
they both have an mm plus 5 so M plus 5n
plus 5 is the binomial factor that they
share